welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode 6 kin in which Brothers
reunite and teach each other what
communism is whatever Kami Mountain life
Tommy's been living if he was a Desert
Storm vet at least 18 years old in 1991
and it's 2023 now he looks pretty damn
good for post-apocalyptic 50. let's
break down this episode scene by scene
for all the references to the game and
the details you missed there is a lot of
stuff to talk about from the game but I
will save the spoilers stuff for the end
in spoiler corner and by the way our new
channel the Deep dive is now live with a
great slate of Premium film analysis
videos for you to check out subscribe
over at Deep dive NR and you can also
support our growing Network by getting
something at nerd riot.shop like this
last of us shirt or something from the
deep dive collection this guy's called
the Bossman speaking of commies okay we
begin back in the chilling moment in KC
from episode 5 when Henry shoots salmon
decides to take his own life one detail
I didn't mention is how after painting
that orange Super Sam eye mask on his
brother as Henry looked out the window
at Joel and Ellie the reflection casts
an orange stripe over his eyes too the
fact that he could not save his brother
leaves Joel with a grim beer that he too
could fail As a caretaker which is why
he begs for Tommy to take Ellie it is
really the core emotional through line
of this episode we jump ahead three
months later to a cabin in the Wyoming
Wilderness the home of marlin and his
wife Florence original characters for
this series we see a stack of firewood a
hundred bucks antlers scraping the snow
and reminded of Bill's Home in Lincoln
the firewood that he chopped in the
hunted game that he suspended and
dressed in his shed Marlin has bow
hunted a few white rabbits and comes in
just seeing the look on Florence's face
knowing that intruders are in the house
and I just love Graham Green's happy now
smile when he pulls the gun out he's
such a good actor who's shown up at a
ton of titles like Dances with Wolves I
love this actor now Ellie refuses to
stay hidden upstairs and Joel demands as
they point on the map where they are and
your answer better be the same as your
wives did you tell them the truth yeah
are you telling me the truth
yeah yeah I love that Marlin still can
never really tell what games his wife
might be playing Marlon asks about the
town of Cody where Joel was previously
headed you seeing Cody yeah I got close
enough it's crawling with infected
Laramie Wind River Reservation yeah Wind
River Reservation is in Wyoming and it's
a setting and name of a Wyoming region
where Taylor Sheridan's 2017 film Wind
River takes place in which Graham green
co-stars alongside Elizabeth Olsen and
Jeremy Renner it's an amazing film check
it out outside Ellie takes one of the
two rabbits that Marlin caught the
smaller one and Joel tells her to leave
it but it's this moment that seems to
send Joel into his panic attack why is
that well I believe the two rabbits
represent the two daughter figures in
Joel's life Sarah and Ellie white fur
representing innocence the color white
he now sees all around him the further
and further west he goes his paternal
empathy is starting to merge these two
young women Ellie taking the smaller one
triggers him to think about the older
daughter that he left behind meanwhile
Joel is the hanging deer bleeding out in
the snow the way he ends this episode
you dying
okay okay I'm okay no no where are you
because just a reminder that you're dead
I'm fine I love how Ellie stumbles On
the Line it's gonna be easy
all we have to do is cross the river of
death in Greek mythology the river of
death is the River Styx which All Souls
must travel to reach the underworld this
episode is marking the break into the
third Act of the Season where Joel and
Ellie are crossing over into the darkest
parts of their Journey Gustavo Santo
alalas guitar strings score their walk
across the landscape a rare instance of
us hearing it within the runtime of an
episode by the campfire Joel tapes his
boot reminding us of tests back in
episode 2 and Ellie sees the Northern
Lights Aurora Borealis at this time of
year at this time of day in this part of
the country as she tells Joel later in
the scene her dream is to be an
astronaut like Sally Ride and I totally
agree with Ellie Sally Ride an amazing
astronaut name now again it has been
three months but only now does Ellie
reveal I tried with Sam tried what I
knew he was infected I rubbed some of my
blood into his bite I know I know it was
stupid I wanted to save him well I
reckon it's a lot more complicated than
that and not to Bumm us out too much by
focusing on last week but it is worth
noting that even after his infection
took over Sam still sat facing away from
away from Bill even though as we saw
with Ms Adler in episode 1 and confirmed
by The Producers cordyceps fixes your
physical ailments and Neil druckman and
Craig Mason even said that what Sam
worried that when he become the monster
might still be you inside might be the
case for salmon that moment jolsons are
off to bed
sheep ranches on the moon yeah I love
that Joel combines their separate dreams
into a mutual shared dream we match cut
from this nighttime campfire to the
morning and Joel mumbles in his sleep
yeah Joel is saying it's supposed to be
me he's failing Survivor skill and
inadequacy that he was never supposed to
walk this path he should be dead and
falling asleep proves Joel's fear right
I'm responsible for you okay then don't
fall asleep this is an inverse of
jolinelli from episode 4 when Joel was
able to let Ellie sleep while he kept
watch at night and then later in that
episode Ellie still fell asleep
immediately on the drive as Joel and
Ellie cross what they think is the river
of death I love the little detail of the
snow clumped up on their backpacks
something the customer the scent
decorator probably would have added to
the actors to make sure they look like
they've been outside for a while and
speaking of the great outdoorsy costume
of the show I am wearing this awesome
warm canvas jacket given to us by
friends of huckberry you can get one of
your own by clicking the link in the
description okay so they arrive at this
hydroelectric Dam damn your no will
Livingston yeah yeah but who is so that
made electricity yeah don't ask me I
don't have a clue you know you could
have just made something up well
Livingston of course the author of no
pun intended and remember after Ellie
asked Joel how Gas stipending Works he
has learned to not even begin trying now
this dam is actually the location of the
Jackson events of part one of the game
and here we see residents are in the
process of getting the generator
operational the HBO series jumps past
that showing us the full town to give
Joel and Ellie a glimpse of a
comfortable safe home life that they
could have and really a constructive
light that Tommy has made for himself
after he left his brother but the
Cavalry uses this dog to sniff the
quarter steps on them remember back in
episode 1 the Adler dog Mercy sensed the
infection on Mrs Adler so we know dogs
can detect this and Joel freezes as he
goes into another panic attack
hey hey
so why doesn't the dog smell the
cordyceps in Ellie's arm well it might
be that dogs can only smell quarter
steps if it has spread throughout the
body and taken over the brain stem but
either way Ellie is a new form of human
adaptation to the fungus and dogs in
their Immortal Divine character judgment
ability just love humans who won't ever
turn on them now we see the town of
Jackson and it is thriving there's the
Tipsy Bison Bar from the games the
banners for the Jackson Lights Festival
2003 you think they would have taken
them down by now but maybe they're just
nostalgic Ellie passes a woman in a
wheelchair and kids making snowmen
showing how this community is stable
enough to care for children and the
elderly Joel and Tommy reunite come here
to save you
laughs
it's a bit different from the games
where there's a bit more hesitancy
between the brothers when they first see
each other but notice that Ellie's
expression it's mixed and jealous she
senses that she is now a bit less
important in Joel's life she wishes she
had that immediate family connection
Ellie's making friends what
what's wrong with you what about her
manners she was just curious
kids around here don't usually look or
talk like you well maybe I'll teach them
now this girl isn't named here but she
could have been someone important in the
future of the series I'm gonna get to
that more in spoiler corner at the end
of the video Tommy reveals that he and
Maria are together oh [__] congrats
don't say congrats
congrats yeah I love that same Force
friendliness that Joel Just mutters out
through his gritted teeth the same that
he used on Henry last episode everything
is great dude so we get a full tour of
Jackson house of worship multi-faith
School
laundry oh Bank works as the jail not
that we've needed it yeah they don't
need the bank anymore because there's no
capital in this commune but it sounds
like they also don't need the jail
either because people don't break the
law or they get shot if they do or maybe
both Tommy says I'll share Collective
ownership
so uh communism I didn't like that it is
that literally this is the commune we're
communists
yeah it's funny how in the seven years
that he's been here Tommy really never
made the connection to showing how a lot
of people don't really understand what
communism actually is La meets the pony
named Shimmer that is the name of a
horse in part two of the game Joel tells
Tommy doesn't seem like you age much you
on the other hand okay so Gabriel Luna
is 40 years old probably around 39 when
he shot this Pedro Pascal is 47 probably
around 46 when he shot this so Tommy
should be at least 50 if he served in
the Gulf War Joel is a few years older
than that so I love that they at least
acknowledge how young these actors look
even though they gray up Pedro Pascal a
bit Tommy asks how's Tess she's fine
all right good then
and the kid she's the daughter of some
Firefly monkey muck yeah Joel has to lie
about Tess initially because if he
reveals how she died he'll have to
reveal everything about Ellie but as a
side effect of this because he tells
Tommy that he's moving to Ellie for a
payment Tommy continues to see his
brother as a morally corrupt person who
hasn't moved on from that life of
killing people to get by Tommy doesn't
want to take Joel to Eastern Colorado
University because he's going to be a
father I feel like I'd be a good dad
guess we'll find out
I guess we'll find out
that's all you got what else am I
supposed to say guess the whole idea of
fatherhood still stings for Joel he once
considered himself a good dad but now he
sees the whole idea fatherhood is just
setting one up for failure and Joel has
another panic attack but notice how
Pedro Pascal is blinking rapidly at
first but then he stops and goes
wide-eyed when he looks over to Sea a
woman who from behind looks exactly like
Sarah but it turns out she is a mom who
hugs her daughter a daughter who looks
like even younger Sarah since it is 20
years since Sarah's death Sarah would
have been old enough to be a mom and
Joel could have been a grandfather he's
seen the entire erase timeline of his
family tree now at this point in my life
I have turned my brain into a cluttered
junk drawer full of nerd trivia and
because that clever brain uses my
MacBook it was cluttered too until I got
clean my Mac X playing my Mac X is the
best software on the planet to clean and
optimize your Mac it deletes Mega tons
of junk malware and it uninstalls unused
apps and makes Mac computers faster
safer and more organized it's so good
that it's been notarized by Apple
themselves and if anybody knows how to
keep a Mac clean it's the people who
build them right clean my Mac X has a
whole bunch of tools you can use to
clean up your Mac smart scan find system
files you no longer need space lens will
show you what files are taking up the
most room on your hard drive and malware
removal will find those nasty little
viruses and junk programs you didn't
even know you had once your Mac is
healthy clean my Mac X's menu app will
help you keep it healthy by giving you
an easy way to look at Key performance
indicators on your computer no wonder
clean my Mac X has been an industry
leader in Mac health for 14 years it
even won the Red Dot award which is
basically the Oscars of app design it's
used by millions of people in 185
countries around the world plus
Antarctica right to get started making
your Mac run like new just click the
link in the description to download
cleanmymacx today Ellie showers in this
teenage girls room where a bunch of
teenage stuff is pinned on the cork
board ranking the 10 hottest boys number
one Freddy tops number two Taylor marks
number three Benny neufeld number four
Chad Wilson number five Ben Monty writes
hotter with a haircut so he was Arrow to
number one also in the lower left we see
a photo of Ben I assume that's
pre-haircut where he wrote stay cool
ever change number six Scotty r with an
arrow pointing to a beach photo by the
way sorry other Scotty in Jackson
Wyoming 2003. you didn't make the list
buddy number seven Ricky Barney number
eight Marshall Martin's arrow pointing
to Marshall on a stage Tammy's faves she
called dibs I like how she wrote the
plural version of tammys IES not y
apostrophe s but whoever this girl is
grammatical and spelling errors
everywhere number nine Dawson P then
crossed out not yikes what happened to
you Dawson number 10 Hunter Phelps and
then an asterisk Professor smeds Rolo's
fave also how old was this girl do you
call your high school teacher's
Professor there's also a note from a
secret admirer and then some emo song
lyrics no one can hear me when I tell
him I'm sad and I can't go on and then
the chorus Nobody But Me Nobody about me
will ever rise up the bullies and later
in this room we see this girl has a
poster for radiohead's creep and an iMac
desktop from the early odds Maria left
out for Ellie a diva cup a very
practical thing considering how glad
Ellie was to find tampons three months
ago since subject is hardly ever covered
in post-apocalyptic fiction I do just
like how menstruation is a reality for
these characters La finds the names
Kevin and Sarah written on the
chalkboard candles in front of each of
them Kevin was Maria's son born April
3rd 2000 and died a few days after
outbreak Day meaning he was three years
old with his mother Maria a story that I
really just don't want to see Ever
please Last of Us don't show us that and
of course Sarah that was Joel's daughter
Tommy's niece died at age 14 the night
after outbreak day outbreak day was the
26th and this was after midnight when
she died Maria reveals that Sarah was
Joel's daughter and they argue about
Joel's character there's a whole lot
you're not telling me
good the only people who can betray us
are the ones we trust I like that we
have the sinkers in the game we never
really cut away from Joel's point of
view so now we get to see how Ellie
found out and it was a result of this
nice casual moment Between Women where
one is cutting the other one split ends
just two women looking out for each
other now this town screens the 1977
film The Goodbye Girl written by Neil
Simon this was the first rom-com to
gross over 100 million dollars Richard
Dreyfuss won best actor for playing
Elliot who's an actor who moves him with
a woman Paula of the two-point
friendship and it's really sweet he
promises to never leave them but he gets
a huge job offer that he can't turn down
he has to make a big decision of course
parallel to Joel's dilemma in this
episode a man who gets stuck with a girl
and has to decide if he's actually up to
be your caretaker and I love how they
are screening this in the same mess hall
where Joel and Ellie ate earlier
everything is multi-purpose Joel tells
Tommy that Ellie is immune and
emotionally confesses how inadequate he
feels to take care of her and how his
dreams are making him feel I just know
that when I wake up I've lost something
I'm failing in my sleep that's all I do
it's all I've ever done is failure again
now we get to this big moment where
Ellie is reading the girl's diary in the
room but we actually see a close-up of
the Diary page here and you can read I
hate my family mom told me she would
take me to the mall something about me
and my big mouth and then she writes
jeez I'm crying on the page geez spelled
geese and then Holly stepmom has left my
dad I feel so bad it's all very true and
typical teenage girl emotions that Ellie
can't at all relate with boys movies
deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt
it's bizarre now all this is almost a
line for line adaptation from The
Amazing scene in the game where Joel
finds Ellie and they have this
heartbreaking argument except in the
game it comes after Ellie runs away on a
horse to a nearby ranch house and Joel
has to chase her down I think it's great
that they kept most of the dialogue the
same even the wallpaper of the room is
exactly the same you have no idea what
loss is you have no idea what loss is
now there is no euron Mighty thin ice
line but the big difference I've noticed
is that in the game they're interrupted
by Tommy running in and you gotta fight
some Raiders here it just ends on this
heavy emotional beat which forces us to
stay in the headspace of the characters
now in this room behind Joel on the wall
is a poster of a giraffe around this
section of the game Joel and Ellie to
find giraffeus Joel and Visions
decorating a Christmas tree with Sarah
his wrist watch is still working
unbroken so was this before Sarah died
well probably not because it sounded
like his watch hadn't worked in years so
this must have been a fantasy in which
Sarah survived until three months after
outbreak day through Christmas 2003 and
then from this moment Joel's mind then
drifts to Sarah h14 from the morning
they ate their final meal from his point
of view as he sat across from her that
kitchen table and she wore that same
lavender shirt so Joel decides to give
Ellie the choice on whether she wants
him as her guardian and she says yes the
attempt some target practice with
Tommy's rifle and his new scope that he
mentioned before Joel proves Ellie Wrong
by firing a hole right in the H of
[__] explains what a contractor was
what people's politics used to be and he
explains football and turnovers first
downs and Ellie just sums it up so
basically just moving in One Direction
basically
but violent oh well there's that another
parallel to their Journey moving in One
Direction there's always violence but in
a constant fear of fumbling the football
that football being Ellie as in the
games you do run into some monkeys who
used to be in the zoology Labs meanwhile
the way Joel and Ellie find the monkeys
instead of clickers upstairs is just
like it is in the game well at least it
ain't clickers at least an eight
clickers we find the fireflies have
cleared out of the university hospital
with a packing list that mentioned Salt
Lake City and upstairs they find a map
with pins leading to Salt Lake City and
Saint Mary's on that map which is a
hospital they will be headed to White
pin seemed to lead from Colorado where
they are but there are other separate
pin Trails blue leading Southwest to
Southern California red leading upward
to Seattle Green moving east across the
Great Plains white continuing Southeast
toward New Mexico Joel and Ellie run
into a group of Raiders and Joel breaks
one guy's neck but gets a jagged shank
stabbed into his gut which he pulls out
and I know Craig Mason knows this
because he's talked about it at length
on his script notes podcast but despite
what you see in TV shows and movies you
should never pull out an object that
gets stabbed into you now we shouldn't
expect Joel to know that but Mesa knows
how much worse Joel just made it in the
game the weapon is a piece of rebar but
here it looks like a broken end of a
baseball bat Joel goes into shock as he
bleeds and Ellie freaks out
I don't know where they're going what
the [__] I'm gonna do last episode we
learned Ellie's greatest fear I'm scared
of ending up alone and now that is where
she seems to be the music we hear over
the end is a softer cover of Depeche
Mode's never let me down again that was
a song that ended episode one and it was
a song that Craig Mason promised would
come back later in the season here it is
remember that 80s song was in that
moment like all 80s songs meant to
communicate danger ahead according to
Frank's radio code so in addition to
Danger approaching we also in this
episode in Joel's Greatest fear and
Ellie's greatest fear together just like
the way he merged their dreams of sheep
on the moon now their greatest fears are
merged together she is facing being left
alone he is facing being too weak to be
able to take care of a daughter figure
and speaking of fathers and daughters
the vocalist covering never let me down
again is actually Craig Mason's own
daughter Jessie so episode 1 was male
gen xers singing these words now it's a
solitary voice of a gen zir singing it
back to them in a kind of broken prayer
okay there's quite a bit to discuss here
in sports the corner and there's gonna
be spoilers for both The Last of Us Part
One and Last of Us Part two games coming
ahead so this episode jumps ahead three
months and I don't think it's meant to
just show the passage of time Beyond
Henry and Sam practically speaking it
also gives Marlene enough time to make
it from the Boston Cuisine to Salt Lake
City setting up her return in the events
of the hospital that I assume will be
this season's finale Ellie's dream of
becoming an astronaut setting up the
moment in the game when Joel takes her
to a NASA exhibit as a birthday present
with an audio recording that allows her
to imagine she's an astronaut in the
games we do not see Jackson until after
the events of Salt Lake City of course
really the opening section is a part two
of the game so a lot of this stuff from
part two they hint to that in this
episode and that includes the girl who
stares at Ellie humili yells at who most
likely will be revealed as Dina her
partner from part two of the game their
introduction in the game is pretty
similar to what we see here also he
probably caught Joel mentioning he
wanted to be a singer sounds like this
might be setting up the whole thing of
Joel saying he wanted to teach Ellie
guitar and singing in the game but most
importantly the map it's interesting for
one Trail to lead back toward New Mexico
and Texas because in the game Tommy
tells Joel at the day him that he had
gone back to Austin at some point went
back to their house most of it had been
looted except a photo of Joel and Sarah
and Joel does not want the photo the
fact that we don't see that moment here
in this episode makes me wonder if they
might be saving that moment for the
season finale also on that map yeah
trails to Seattle and a trail to
Southern California Seattle a very
important location to go to in part two
and then after Seattle you go on a trip
to Santa Barbara and looking for a
firefly community on Catalina Island so
I think this map right here charts out
everything we're headed to in season two
okay another reminder to subscribe to
the Deep dive and watch one of the
amazing launch Day videos that we have
on the channel and sporty rockstars by
going to nerdrive.shop we had this last
inspired shirt it's awesome but if you
want me to close my jacket this
huckberry jacket's also very cool links
for both in the description below you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at EA boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
foreign
[Music]